why is the Labour Party misleading the
country about having to do a deal with
the SNP in the event of a minority labor
government let me be playing we're not
going to do a deal with the Scottish
National Party we're not going to have a
coalition we're not going to have a deal
and let me just say this to you Simon if
the if it meant if it meant we weren't
going to be in government not doing a
coalition not having a deal then so be
it
I'm not going to sacrifice the future of
our country the unity of our country I'm
not going to give in to SNP demands
around trident around the deficit or
anything like that so I just want to
repeat this point to you I'm not going
to have a Labour government if it means
deals so coalition's with the Scottish
national parties and I sort of say this
to voters in Scotland David there's no
easy route here to vote SNP and get a
Labour government if you want to Labour
government you need to vote Labour so
when are the members of the Shadow
Cabinet say that they were open to deal
so you disagree with that I do and I'm
the leader and you're not going to have
deal and you wouldn't put forward a
Queen's Speech on the hood that they'd
support it you just wouldn't go to the
Queen and and accept invitations we do
want to put forward a Labour Queen
speech I want a majority Labour
government and it would be for parties
in the House of Commons to vote for it
but you asked me about deals you asked
me about coalition's they're not going
to happen I couldn't be clearer with you
what you said something rather
interesting then you said you'd rather
not have a Labour government yeah then
then have a Labour government supported
by the SNP a Labour government with a
coalition or a deal the alligator's real
in your in your welcomes I've been asked
about lots of different kind of deals
coalition so what they call courageously
want to explain which is misters in your
cabinet yeah but what is a deal
confidence and supply they said which is
where you you sort of have an
arrangement I'm not doing that I'm not
doing that and I want to explain why
right so sorry so you'd rather lose
office so to speak you'd rather not have
a Labour government if in the price of
having a Labour government was a
coalition or a deal with the Scottish
National Party it's not going to happen
okay